what's going on guys this is Rob and as
promised as promised Black Adam versus
the DC Universe world war three and this
story is cool now here's one of the
things to understand world war three is
Again part of DC's 52 weeks so there are
a lot of things that happen over the
course of the events of World War III
most of them have nothing to do with
Black Adam whatsoever it's just kind of
a continuation of DC building up like
other characters and things like that so
we're basically gonna ignore it and
we're only gonna focus on Black Adam
essentially facing off against the DC
Universe and let me tell you something
man he wrecks everyone and the first
thing that happens here right in bialya
in the last video that we did you'll
find a link to that video down in the
description if you want to get caught up
it's not overly complicated or anything
but in the last video that we did
basically Black Adam his family had been
killed by people out there in the world
and the response to this is that he
basically is taking his Vengeance out on
the world one of the first places he
goes to is bialya because the various
individuals who killed his family that's
where the last one was hiding out at and
in fact bialya which is essentially a
corrupt country run by a corrupt
government it allowed that person in now
wind like Adam was there Not only was
the government that corrupt that when he
arrived there the people actually
started attacking him so he killed
everyone men women kids the whole nine
yards everybody died right no one was
spared and so in response to this with
him having killed so many people this
young girl appears right and her
question is you know why did you do all
this right only a select few were
responsible for your loss yet Millions
have paid the price and the initial
response of Black Adam is like you speak
beyond your years right you have no idea
what you're talking about only to find
out this girl has super strength and the
reason why this girl has super strength
is because this is not a little girl
this my friends is Martian Manhunter and
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with Martian Manhunter this
guy's on par with Superman right and in
fact depending on who you talk to and
even during Grant Morrison's JLA run
from 1998 Superman has actually stated
that Martian Manhunter is more powerful
than he is right this guy gets
demolished this is how pissed off Black
Adam is right this is how mad Black Adam
is Martian Manhunter initially just goes
after this guy and just starts attacking
him but really it's more to subdue that
Black Adam himself is fighting to kill
he's fighting to destroy right literally
it's just unbridled rage so much so this
guy's almost foaming at the mouth and so
when Martian Manhunter goes after Black
Adam literally as soon as they touch
Martian Manhunter tries to override his
mind but because of black Adam's age
combined with his various Powers his
mind is not so easily dominated and so
in that moment when they're making
contact he literally just shouts Shazam
that lightning comes down and
immediately Burns Martian Manhunter and
because of that like black Adam seizes
him by the throat and it's like okay
Martian Manhunter like you want to get
into my head you want to see what's
going on in my mind then let me show you
my friend and he literally forces
Martian Manhunter to witness all the
people that Black Adam annihilated all
the innocent lives that were totally
destroyed on top of that he forces
Manhunter to feel all the pain and
anguish that he's experiencing from the
loss of his family now one of the things
to know is that when it comes to the
telepathy of Martian Manhunter it's kind
of hit and miss and this is one of those
stories where like how easy it is to
override his empathy and his emotional
telepathy you know it changes based on
who's writing the stories sometimes it's
absolute and Resolute and unshakable in
this instance it's not and in fact
because of the extreme emotional toll
the Black Adam is experiencing and
because the empathy of Martian Manhunter
is so incredibly strong then it
basically leads to him sort of going
insane and kind of having a temporary
crisis now the reality of here the
reality of this is he's going to be a
background character because in the
aftermath of this he's just going to be
like I don't know man is Humanity really
worth a damn I'll just hang out here and
find out like I'll just sit in space and
find out the important distinction here
is because of black Adam's actions in
bialya and because you're talking about
a guy who was able to go toe-to-toe with
Superman and hold his own the world is
horrified because if Black Adam comes
after their country there's nothing they
can do to stop them so much so that like
Amanda Waller starts reforming the
suicide squad countries start
considering the nuclear option that this
literally could boil down to World War
III even like the Guardians of the
universe who run the Green Lantern Corps
are keeping an eye on Earth because it's
just like this guy can leave the planet
right like he he's like Superman he can
leave Earth and like if he comes to owa
for example is the Green Lantern Corps
going to be enough to hold him back the
Joker thinks it's funny as hell but
regardless of this whole thing like
Black Adam is just losing his mind and
he actually literally starts going after
like the military right taking out these
aircraft carriers vessels the whole nine
yards and so you have like attempt after
attempt by just military might to take
this guy on and find some way to destroy
him and in fact he even goes after
father time and rips his face off now
something to know here about this
confrontation with Father time there's a
couple things going on here the first is
that father time isn't necessarily some
god-like being I mean he kind of is but
kind of isn't the niche behind father
time is that on New Year's Day every
year he basically casts aside an old
body and basically reforms a new one so
the fact that his face is torn off is
really more of an inconvenience until
however long it takes for him to find a
new body and then to take that body over
on New Year's Day and that's basically
it but the bigger picture here is that
he's basically leading or at least the
field commander of Checkmate now
Checkmate in DC Comics is kind of a
interesting sort of Quagmire think of it
as a combination of like Marvel's shield
and like DC Suicide Squad to a degree
because it's actually an offshoot of
task force x which is kind of where you
get the suicide squad from but the
important thing here is these are guys
who are exceedingly capable and Black
Adam tears all of them apart with the
greatest of ease and so that's kind of
the big concern is how do you defeat a
guy with this level of power and so what
we end up doing here is picking up with
Black Adam in Italy when he faces off
against the Doom Patrol the important
thing here is these guys have a very
unique set of powers among them in terms
of what they're capable of but I also
want to point out none of them are
strong enough to defeat Black Adam like
not by a mile right I mean again this is
a guy that went toe-to-toe with Superman
it's not going to happen right it's it's
just not going to take place but this
ultimately leads to him facing off
against the arrival of the Titans or the
Teen Titans if you want to call it that
now these guys are a step up and I hope
that's one of the things you're noticing
here is that it's kind of a hierarchy of
who Black Adam is facing off against he
starts off against the military he goes
into Doom Patrol and then he goes into
the Titans Teen Titans whatever and then
he'll start graduating higher and going
against some pretty heavy hinners and
the thing about this is that even with
the Teen Titans he doesn't want to
annihilate them in their entirety he has
no desire to destroy them now one of the
funny things is that ultimately he just
gets fed up and that's one of the things
to know about Black Adam whenever you
run up on Black Adam right and you're
just like I'm gonna fight you right
initially he'll kind of be like okay
look man I mean I get that you want to
but like this is not a fight you need to
have right I'm not the guy that you
fight here you leave me alone I'll leave
you alone everything will be okay and
under in a normal circumstance that's
exactly what the Teen Titans would do
they would just kind of like okay the
Titans would just be like all right cool
man you do your thing we'll be over here
doing whatever it is that we do right
watching SpongeBob SquarePants and
that'll basically be it the Black Adam
is going on just a an absolute Massacre
across the world just eradicating the
populations of all these different
cities and so they have to act they have
to step in and so ultimately what ends
up happening is the fight reaches a
point where black Adam's like okay fine
like if what you guys wanted to fight
with me if that's really what you want
then I will give you a fight right if
what you want is to fight Black Adam
then I will let you fight like Adam and
you will fight Black Adam in his
entirety I'm not gonna hold back yes
Black Adam refers to himself in third
person I really wish he did it would be
awesome if he did but you end up getting
Frankenstein who at this point in time
is basically DC's crappy version of The
Incredible Hulk who steps up to face off
against Black Adam dude gets his arms
ripped off and Black Adam kills him on
the spot right like literally destroys
him and then it's just like holy cow and
then he flies away so like the Titans
are just like come on team we gotta get
him and Raven's like are you insane like
there's no way we're gonna go after
Black Adam and try to overpower this guy
but they do anyway right they go after
blackout him anyway so ultimately when
they finally catch up to him they're
just fighting out above Mount Everest in
the Himalayas and again he's like look
guys I've killed one of you to show you
guys that you don't stand a chance if
you keep this up I will keep on killing
people people and they're like well you
know we have to we have we can't we
can't let you keep on doing this
whatever and even Raven tries to use her
powers on Black Adam and it's not enough
and so what this does is it actually
leads into Terror stepping in now Tara
is a long-standing member of the Teen
Titans and when I say she's a
long-standing member I mean she's been
involved with the titans of the Teen
Titans initially she started off as a
villain because I know people are going
to be like you're actually that's true
she originally started off as a villain
and she was actually an ally and kind of
a weird twist like the lover of
Deathstroke which is really really
strange but ultimately like she was able
to hold her own against the Teen Titans
it was cool to see but the fact that
she's on the team now and the fact that
she controls literally the Earth itself
it's like Waging War against the world
now it's not one of those things where
she can just like send the Earth flying
into the Sun or something like that but
it's one of those things where like
she's able to hold her own to a degree
against somebody like like Adam or at
least you would think so because this
girl conjures two Boulders and smashes
them into Black Adam and Black Adam
looks over at better he's like man girl
you better come strong goes flying to
this girl and pushes a hole right in her
chest and that's the end of Tara kills
her on the spot right and that's when
the Titans are just like oh damn right
that's when people wake up to the
reality of the situation the Black Adam
is he's Playing for Keeps this guy this
guy's not pulling punches man right this
guy's not messing around like this guy's
100 like get in my way and I will
destroy you right I don't care who you
are in the superhero Community it's
important that you understand that right
do not be confused about your place in
the bigger picture and so with all these
Mass casualties happening with Black
Adam taking out Doom Patrol which
doesn't matter and then taking out the
Titans which does matter is basically
the JSA and all of the World Superheroes
minus Batman Superman and Wonder Woman
Who come to the realization that this
guy has to be stopped in some form or
another this guy has to be ended in some
capacity now inevitably people are going
to ask the question and where are Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman the reality is
that during the events of Infinite
Crisis they were all just kind of
dealing with their own inner demons so
to speak so like during Infinite Crisis
for example Wonder Woman had killed
Maxwell Lord after he had seized control
of Superman so she was basically coming
to terms with that Batman was training
right doing his whole thing and dealing
with his inner problems Superman was
doing the same thing it was one aspect
of DC's in uh DC's 52 event that I never
really liked because you would think
Black Adam wreaking havoc across the
world and basically killing most
everyone would be reason enough for like
them to just like show up and just be
like hey so like I'm gonna take a break
from my meditation and training because
like basically an evil version of
Superman is killing everyone instead I
guess it was just kind of like I mean
they got it right if everybody else dies
we'll step up but like until that
happens right you know they got it they
can take care of it but in any event
like that's the answer to why they were
out of the picture but the important
thing here is that because of of the
wrath of Black Adam pretty much
everybody in the DC Superhero landscape
on Earth has come together to find some
way to stop Black Adam and none of it
seems to work but that's an important
distinction here is because initially
they don't confront Black Adam and the
reason why they don't confront him is
because with him being in China and this
is actually covered in issue number zero
of uh World War III it wasn't part of
the original four issue series that
industry number zero what you learned is
that because you're talking about
entangling political alliances because
you're talking about like airspace and
and Sovereign Nations and so on that the
JSA and the other members of the
superhero Community can't just show up
in other countries they can't just go
there right because it would be
considered an active Invasion right it'd
be considered an act of war and so they
kind of have to wait for those countries
to basically allow them in now this is
one of those instances where the good
guys usually lose because they care
about the rules and the bad guys don't
so the bad guys basically get what they
want because Black Adam doesn't hear
about the rules right I mean this is a
superhero story so ultimately it ends
with the good guys winning but in the
real world the bad guys win because they
don't care about the rules and the good
guys let the rules hold them back but
the thing about this is that with
Martian Manhunter kind of observing
everybody it's sort of a calm before the
storm it's him just kind of walking
around and coming to this realization
that for all these different people here
they all acknowledge that they might not
survive this battle that Black Adam
might kill them all right it's entirely
possible because they understand the
strength and power of Black Adam now
what ends up happening is that Martian
Manhunter leads a full contingent of the
earth superheroes against Black Adam now
the question a lot of you guys are
probably going to be asking here is
where's Shazam where's Billy Batson in
all of this okay so that's answered in
issue number zero and it's kind of
amazing that it wasn't part of this
story but in issue number zero one of
the first things that had happened is
that with Black Adam basically going
nuts that he had faced off against like
Billy Batson and the Shazam family and
overpowered all of them right because he
wasn't pulling back and they're doing
what good guys do right they were always
holding back and the result of this is
that with them being so immensely
overpowered they
were like Adam so what ended up going on
is that Billy Batson who is now kind of
the new Shazam right like the wizard
Shazam he's the one that sits on the
throne and the rock of Eternity so what
he ended up dealing was basically going
to the Egyptian gods because that's
where Black Adam gets his powers from
and asks them to basically de-power
Black Adam and their response was no
like we're not going to do that we
actually agree with what he's doing
right and so as a result there was no
way for Billy Batson to overpower those
gods and so Billy Batson had to try to
find some other way and so what was
going on is that in the background on
the magical side while all this was
happening that they were trying to find
some way to basically de-power Black
Adam right to shut his powers down
because there just didn't really seem to
be a way to pull this off especially if
he was backed by the powers of the Gods
and so when the JSA makes their move
right the entirety of the superhero
Community launches their attack against
Black Adam it's it's an absolute
bloodbath like that's one of the things
that I want to point out here man it's a
bloodbath dude like it's it's just it's
it's crazy because no one stands a
chance against these guys and it kind of
makes sense because unless you're
talking about someone like Superman or
you're talking about Martian Manhunter
at the peak of his power or you're
talking about Billy Batson right or
something along those lines there are
precious few people out there who could
defeat Black Adam now one of the things
that is addressed in this story is like
where's the Specter right like given
everything that black Adam's doing like
the Specter represents God's judgment
and the Specter could basically step in
and essentially defeat Black Adam the
answer is that in the aftermath of final
crisis I'm sorry Infinite Crisis the
Specter is picking a new host who will
become Christmas Allen and the answer
the reality here is Christmas isn't
fully on board and hasn't really made a
determination as to whether or not he's
willing to even be the host of the
Specter which means without a physical
form there's no real way for the Specter
to get involved here now the reality is
that there is right I mean they could do
that it's just a way to keep the Specter
out of the story so that it's not just
some kind of MacGuffin like here comes
blackout I'm destroying the world okay
well then here comes just this nigh
omnipotent being who's just gonna end
the story for us because we don't know
how else to end it but it's just
basically a way to avoid that from
happening the ending is actually really
really cool here but the thing about
this is that with with Black Adam I mean
this guy dominates the entirety of the
superhero landscape and there's really
nothing they can do because again what
you're talking about here is you're
talking about a guy who's fighting not
holding back he doesn't care about the
rules he doesn't care about preserving
life or anything like that and the
superheroes are fighting a war on two
fronts they're fighting a war fighting
this conflict against Black Adam trying
to bring him down while trying to
minimize collateral damage and that
would seem to be their weakness at least
those who were here fighting in the
moment but the thing about this is that
the magical side ultimately intervenes
because if there's no way to make Black
Adam say the word Shazam which he won't
voluntarily do and one of the things
that you end up learning is that even if
he did the Egyptian gods would stop that
from happening because they would
basically they don't want him to be
de-powered back into his mortal form so
he might say it by accident or something
along those lines Billy Batson could say
it in his presence and that would
depower Black Adam and you know any
number of things could happen that would
lead to him losing his abilities that
basically he's kind of in his permanent
or in this form permanently until some
measure is called what they end up doing
on the magical side is they summon the
lightning themselves right they
literally use it and call it down
directly now this is huge and it's an
amazing moment because what it shows is
that it's a last-ditch effort that there
was no real conceivable way to do it
that Billy Batson calls down the
lightning the other magical beings
channel that and basically it confines
into Black Adam and it's a really really
cool moment because one of the things
that happens is between really Issue
Number Four of World War four or world
war three and issue number zero there
were a few things happening at the same
time given the power of Black Adam and
given the Wrath that he was experiencing
he could have simply just dodged it he
could have just jumped out of the way
there were a lot of things that could
have happened what you end up finding
out is that what Martian Manhunter had
done is he had seized the Black Adam
again and in doing so where Black Adam
forced Martian Manhunter to experience
all the pain and anguish that he was
going through and to force block Adam to
experience sorry force a Martian
Manhunter to experience all the
individuals who had died in bialya that
what Martian Manhunter does which is why
I guess his journey was kind of
important whatever is that he ends up
forcing Black Adam to experience the the
the sheer just pain and suffering that
people out there are enduring because of
what he's doing so it's the inverse it's
the opposite and while it's not enough
to swayed like Adam and it's not enough
to convince him that he's wrong it is
enough to momentarily keep him subdued
and that's when the lightning gets
called down and that's when Black Adam
basically gets deep power now what's
crazy about this is that you would think
in that moment the Egyptian gods would
immediately reinstate the ability for a
Black Adam to call down the lightning
which presumably they did because he
starts saying the word Shazam but
nothing happens and in fact like Adam
just disappears and the crazy thing here
is like when is when he's basically out
of the picture and the fight's
effectively over the question of like
Jay Garrick The Flash and the other
members of the JSA is like where's Black
Adam right because the Egyptian gods who
have sided with him are going to restore
his powers right they're going to give
him his abilities back all he has to do
is call down the lightning the
responsibility Batson his actions were
genius here he thought about that
beforehand right he realized okay all
Black Adam has to do is just say Shazam
and he gets his powers back so what
Billy Batson did is he used his role on
the rock of Eternity and the power that
Black Adam has and his ability to not
necessarily cut it off but to change the
way in which he accesses it he changed
the word Black Adam has to use in order
to call down his powers to him now Black
Adam for his part realized that pretty
fast he realized that incredibly quickly
the word Shazam doesn't work for him
anymore but the power that he can that
he can use isn't absolute it exists out
there right what he realizes is the word
Shazam doesn't open that door anymore so
he even says things like Captain Marvel
which is what Billy Batson was called
way back in the 40s when he was first
introduced by Bill Parker and CeCe Beck
before Marvel claimed the copyright and
then created their own Captain Marvel
but he also says like conduct he says
Isis he says Batson you know eternity
Osiris just names that he's familiar
with but the funny thing about this is
that the name that Billy Batson used is
a name that Black Adam would never guess
so here's what I want from you guys tell
me what you think the name is but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace